they are fast and they are deadly the
tornado that ripped through this small
town received the second highest
possible danger rating the type of
tornado that is almost mythic in its
scope and power a tornado known as an f4
Barbara Watson rates tornadoes for the
National Weather Service she goes to
areas where tornadoes have hit and
assesses the damage done can you what
was the building before it was either
one of these okay Watson uses the Fujita
scale to rate twisters created by
tornado expert Ted Fujita and adopted by
the Weather Service in 1971 it uses
damage assessments as a gauge to
estimate wind speeds for example an f4
can reduce strong buildings to rubble
with winds up to 260 miles per hour
while it allows them to classify
tornadoes it also helps them better
understand a tornadoes potential to
create havoc
a tornado results in a range of
destruction but its ultimate
classification depends on the worst of
the damage this tornado has been
classified in f4 although not all of the
damage was considered that severe the
Fujita scale also helps us understand
why some buildings are destroyed and
nearby structures are spared homeowner
Jeff posies house was leveled by this f4
tornado there's a screen porch this was
a kitchen then that was all one story
then it went to a tea storage structure
back past that Watson explains that
posies house was probably hit by a
vortex a mini tornado that can spin off
from the larger mass of swirling winds
when you have a very large tornado that
tornado will break down into smaller
vortices that are rotating around each
other
50 yards wide at most and so as that
comes through it's it's kind of hit or
miss as to whether or not one of those
vortices are hitting you Wednes
instantly inside and the building begins
to disintegrate but in reality it was
ten seconds it was gone
thanks to radar and satellite technology
tornadoes now result in fewer casualties
than they once did
Doppler radar which bounces off
condensation has allowed the weather
service to monitor storms that can
spawn tornadoes this is just the
beginning
forecasters can now warn people to seek
shelter before a tornado strikes